[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben dass sich so viele
gewünscht haben zeige ich euch heute das
rezept für meine leckeren amerikaner
[Musik]
die amerikaner sind total saftig und ich
zeige euch jetzt zuallererst die zutaten
für den leckeren teig wir benötigen
zimmer warme und weiche butter außerdem
etwas mehl zucker vanillezucker oder
vanille extrakt je nachdem was ihr da
habt speisestärke backpulver etwas salz
und lauwarme milch
[Musik]
zuallererst nämlich trockenen zutaten
und verhöre sie in einer schüssel
miteinander das ist zum einen das mehl
das backpulver und die speisestärke
die mischung gebe ich dann erstmal an
die seite und es geht weiter mit den
restlichen zutaten
ich gebe zu allererst in meine schüsse
die weiche butter den weißen zucker und
den vanillezucker
[Musik]
das lasse ich dann mit dem knethaken ca
2 minuten cremig rühren
und wer keinen griechen maschine hat
sich der kann selbstverständlich auch
ein handrührgerät verwenden
[Musik]
dann gehe ich mit der geschwindigkeit
ein wenig runter und geben nach und nach
die zwei eier mit dazu
[Musik]
die eier reden wir auch nur so lange
unter bis sich das einigermaßen
verbunden hat denn dann geht es schon
weiter mit den trockenen zutaten
[Musik]
die gebe ich jetzt nicht in einem
schwung mit dazu sondern immer nach und
nach gibt das solchen 56 schritten mit
hinzu und wichtig ist dass sie auch
abwechselnd immer ein paar schlucke
milch mit dazu gibt
[Musik]
damit ihr jetzt auch genau sehen könnt
was derzeit für eine konsistenz hat
zeige ich euch hier nochmal und an der
stelle geben unseren teig in einen
spritzbeutel
[Musik]
sobald ihr den teig dann in den
spritzbeutel eingefüllt habt schneidet
ihr vorne eine großzügige spitze ab
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt es ganz darauf an wie
ihr eure amerikaner mit ich mag sie ganz
gerne genauso groß wie vom bäcker
nebenan ihr könnt aber auch mini
amerikaner draus machen ganz wie ihr
mögt meine amerikaner sind hier im rohen
zustand etwa 7 cm breit und beim backen
werden sie dann etwas größer nach dem
backen haben sie dann einen durchmesser
von 10 cm
[Musik]
bei diesem schritt sollte dir unbedingt
darauf achten dass eure amerikaner auf
dem backblech mit ganz viel abstand
voneinander liegen
ich habe auch nur fünf amerikaner auf
ein blech gelegt denn alles andere wäre
mir zu heikel und dann könnten die
amerikaner ineinander verlaufen und das
wäre dann nicht so schön
nun werden sie im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 175 grad für ca 13 minuten gebacken
mit zwischenzeitig machen wir die glasur
fertig hierfür benötigen wir lediglich
puderzucker und zitronensaft
[Musik]
der zitronensaft wird ausgepresst und
zusammen mit dem puderzucker verrührt
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann so eine konsistenz
erhalten habt sie sollte nicht zu
flüssig aber auch nicht zu fest sein ist
die glasur fertig wenn der amerikaner
sind auch schon aus dem ofen ich glaube
sie vollständig abkühlen lassen und
jetzt gebe ich immer zwei teelöffel
meiner zitronen glasur auf die rückseite
meines amerikaners
[Musik]
zum trocknen lege ich die amerikaner
jetzt auf ein glas so kann es nämlich
nicht passieren dass eure glasur an
einer seite komplett herunter fließt und
sobald sie trocken sind nimmt die sie
dann runter
[Musik]
das sind unsere fertigen amerikaner und
luftdicht verpackt halten sie bis zu
drei tage aber ich glaube kaum dass die
so lange überleben
[Musik]
übrigens habe ich aus dem teig acht
riesengroße amerikaner herausbekommen
nun wünsche ich euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken und sagt es zum nächsten mal
auf die gis kitchen
[Musik]
ach und übrigens falls ihr nicht
verpassen möchte dann hinterlasst mir
noch gerne ein kostenloses abo und wenn
ihr immer auf dem neuesten stand bleiben
möchtet dann folgt mir auf instagram